[Música]
en cuarto de primaria un maestro nos
dijo un día hay tantos números pares
como números de verdad me dije pues si
hay infinitos en cada caso así que
supongo que habrá una misma cantidad
pero por otra parte los pares son sólo
algunos de los enteros también hay
impares así que tiene que haber más
números enteros que pares no para ver lo
que mi maestro quería decir pensemos en
lo que significa que dos conjuntos
tengan el mismo tamaño que quiero decir
cuando afirmo que tengo el mismo número
de dedos en la mano derecha que en la
izquierda está claro que tengo cinco
dedos en cada una pero es más sencillo
no tengo que contar sólo establecer
correspondencia uno-a-uno entre los
dedos de ambas manos de hecho creemos
que algunos pueblos antiguos con idiomas
que carecían de palabras para números
mayores de tres usaban este recurso por
ejemplo si sacas las ovejas a pastar
desde el redil puedes llevar la cuenta
de cuántas salieron apartando una piedra
por cada una y juntando las una a una
cuando las ovejas vuelven así sabría si
falta algunas sin contar realmente otro
ejemplo de que las correspondencias son
más básicas que contar si hablo ante un
auditorio lleno en el que todos los
asientos están ocupados y nadie está de
pie
y el mismo número de sillas que de
personas aunque no sepa cuántas hay de
unas ni de otras así que lo que
realmente queremos decir cuando
afirmamos que dos conjuntos tienen el
mismo tamaño es que entre los elementos
de ambos conjuntos se puede establecer
una correspondencia uno a uno mi maestro
de cuarto nos mostró los números enteros
en fila y debajo su doble como pueden
ver la fila de abajo contiene todos los
números pares y hay una correspondencia
uno-a-uno así que hay tantos números
pares como números pero lo que es
difícil es que parece que los números
pares son sólo una parte de todos los
enteros pero convence esto de que no
tengo los mismos dedos en la mano
derecha y en la izquierda por supuesto
que no no importación no intenta
establecer la correspondencia de una
manera no sea válida eso no nos convence
si uno encuentra una manera de que los
elementos de ambos conjuntos se
correspondan uno a uno entonces decimos
que los dos conjuntos tienen el mismo
número de elementos pueden hacer una
lista de todas las fracciones puede ser
difícil son muchas y no es nada evidente
por cuál empezar o cómo asegurarnos de
que estén todas sin embargo existe una
forma muy inteligente de hacer la lista
de todas las fracciones
kantor la hizo primero a finales del
siglo 19 ponemos todas las fracciones en
una cuadrícula están todas por ejemplo
encontramos 117 sobre 243 en la fila 117
ava y la columna 243 ava ahora creamos
la lista empezando por la esquina
superior izquierda y recorriendo la
diagonalmente una y otra vez saltándonos
las fracciones como 2 sobre 2 que
representan números que ya están
tenemos así una lista de todas las
fracciones lo que significa que hemos
creado una correspondencia 1 a 1 entre
enteros y fracciones a pesar de que
pensábamos que quizá habría más
fracciones ahora es cuando se pone
realmente interesante puede que sepan
que no todos los números reales todos
los que figuran en la recta numérica son
fracciones por ejemplo la raíz cuadrada
de 2 upi los números como estos se
llaman irracionales no porque estén
locos sino porque las fracciones son
razones entre números enteros y por
tanto se llaman racionales lo que
significa que el resto no es decir son
irracionales los irracionales se
representan mediante un número infinito
de decimales que no se repiten podemos
establecer una correspondencia uno a uno
entre los enteros y el conjunto de todos
los decimales los racionales y los
racionales es decir podemos hacer una
lista de todos los números decimales
kantor demostró que no no que no
supiésemos cómo hacerlo sino que no se
puede hacer
supongamos que alguien asegura que ha
hecho una lista de todos los decimales
voy a demostrar que no creando un
decimal que no está en la lista
lo haré cifra a cifra para la primera
cifra decimal de mi número partir de la
primera cifra decimal de ese primer
número si es un 1 la mía será un 2 si no
lo es la mía será un 1 para la segunda
cifra de mi número me fijaré en la
segunda cifra decimal de ese segundo
número de nuevo si la de ustedes es un 1
la mía será un 2 y si no lo es la mía
será un 1 ven cómo funciona el número
decimal que he creado no puede estar en
la lista porque podría ser pongamos el
número 143 ado no porque las 143 abbas
cifra decimal de mi número es distinta
de las 143 abbas cifra de ese 143 hago
número así es cómo la he construido la
lista es incompleta no contiene mi
número decimal imed es la lista que me
des siempre puedo hacer lo mismo y
construir un número que no figure en
ella así que llegamos a ésta la
conclusión los números decimales no
pueden ponerse en una lista representan
una infinidad mayor que la de los
números enteros así que aunque solo
estamos acostumbrados a ver algunos
irracionales como la raíz de 2 o pi la
infinidad de los irracionales es de
hecho mayor que la de las fracciones
alguien dijo una vez que los racionales
las fracciones son como las estrellas
del firmamento y los irracionales son
una oscuridad cantor también demostró
que para cualquier conjunto infinito se
puede crear un infinito mayor que reúna
todos los subconjuntos del conjunto
inicial eso significa que una vez que
tengamos un infinito siempre podemos
crear una mayor construyendo el conjunto
con todos los subconjuntos del primero y
uno aún mayor creando el conjunto de
todos los subconjuntos de este segundo y
así sucesivamente
por tanto hay un número infinito de
infinitos de distintos tamaños si estas
ideas les incomodan no son los únicos
algunos de los más grandes matemáticos
de la época de cantor estaban muy
molestos con estas cosas e intentaron
hacer que los distintos infinitos fuesen
irrelevantes hacer que de alguna manera
las matemáticas pudiesen funcionar sin
ellos cantor llegó a ser vilipendiado
personalmente la situación se complicó y
cayó en una profunda depresión a la
mitad de su vida entrando y saliendo de
centros psiquiátricos pero con el tiempo
sus ideas se impusieron y hoy en día se
consideran fundamentales y magníficas
todos los matemáticos investigadores las
aceptan y se estudian en todas las
universidades y yo te las he explicado
en apenas unos minutos un día quizá
formen parte del saber popular hay más
acabamos de señalar que el conjunto de
números decimales es decir los números
reales es una infinidad mayor que el
conjunto de números enteros kantor se
planteó si habría infinitos de
diferentes tamaños entre esos dos
pensaba que no era así pero no fue capaz
de demostrarlo esta conjetura de kantor
se conoce como hipótesis del continuo en
1900 el gran matemático david hilbert
destacó la hipótesis del continuo como
el problema más importante por resolver
en matemáticas el siglo 20 fue testigo
de la resolución de este problema pero
de una manera completamente inesperada y
disruptiva en los años 20 cord cord
demostró que no se puede demostrar que
la hipótesis del continuo sea falsa
después en los 60 por jay cohen demostró
que tampoco se puede probar que se
acierta juntos ambos resultados implican
que en matemáticas hay preguntas para
las que no existe respuesta una
conclusión realmente asombrosa y las
matemáticas se consideran con razón la
cumbre del razonamiento humano pero
ahora sabemos que incluso las
matemáticas tienen sus limitaciones a
pesar de lo cual siguen proporcionando
cosas realmente fascinantes en las que
pensar ha pensado en el infinito y en el
tiempo existe realmente descúbrelo en
este vídeo y suscríbase a nuestro canal
para viajar hasta los límites del
entendimiento humano
[Música]